Hey! A bit different video today it's
Mental Health Awareness Week if you
If you weren't aware before, you are now!
when I was
younger I-I went personally went through
some tougher times and I strongly think
that having someone to talk to is
extremely important and to share these
emotions with, whether it's a friend a
parent someone you love
don't let it bottle up inside just
telling someone how you really feel can
sometimes be life-changing and it's
extremely important and you may not have
mental health issues yourself but you
can always be there as a helping hand
for someone else and I think this week
is especially a great time to keep
that in mind
suicide is still the leading cause of
death for males between the age of 20
and 50
even though females are more likely to
get depressed they are generally better
at seeking help to others when they do
there's a there's a bit of a stigma for
guys to talk about you know feelings and
all these things it's not it's not cool
enough I mean it's a stigma for
everyone in general but especially males
and if you feel like you don't have
anyone to talk to there's this app
called TalkLife where you can share
whatever emotions or thoughts that you
have and there will be someone there to
listen to you. it's important to not let
feelings get bottled up and try and cope
with it your own and I but at the same
time some things are just really hard to
talk about I you feel like you can't
share it with everyone so I think
TalkLife is a really great solution
to that if you are going through a
crisis I'll link to where you can find
help as well wherever you are in the
world and I think that's extremely
important. I want you to know that it's
okay. it's common to feel this way and
everyone goes through different emotions
throughout their life and there's nothing
wrong with that and there's nothing to
be ashamed about. Like I said I I
struggle with thoughts myself and be
especially being younger and for what
it's worth I think pulling through
you'll be stronger for doing it.
and no matter who you are life is worth
living and better days will come.
I promise. That's it for me today
definitely check out the links I left in
the description it's a really great
chance to be a helping hand this week as
well it could really change someone's life
That's it for me for now. Brofist.